you loved mark ruffalo you tolerated
Edward Norton but admitted you forgot
about Eric Bana until I said his name
just now get ready for the most
forgettable movie about a giant
rage-filled monster ever made in Hulk
before Hulk was an Avenger before he was
even incredible traveled back to a time
when Kevin Feige could still gov a
superhero movie as director Angley
presents a two-hour long brooding think
piece about a green guy who smashes
things stop staring at that bush and hit
something meet Bruce Banner you wouldn't
like it when he's angry or calm or
acting heartbeat
ah he's a monotone unlikable scientist
we're doing the basic science for
everyone working with his ex-girlfriend
Betty a monotone unlikable scientist
you're ahead of the pace I thought you
were in charge in one of the dullest
superhero movies ever made that covers
up its total lack of action with super
whacky scene transitions
Wow it's just like reading a comic book
a terrible boring comic book witness
banners true nature unleashed when a
freak accident turns him into a man who
looks like he's struggling to hold in a
fart until he finally lets it go and
becomes the hero that 2003 CGI clearly
wasn't ready for resulting in a Hulk
that's one part PlayStation cutscene one
part frat guy and two parts Shrek
Hulk his love Hulk his life all anyone
wants to see is the Hulk go up against
someone of equal or greater strength
well too bad because this time the Green
Giant is going toe-to-toe with
lightweight non threats like this douche
the US military's fall might of a few
tanks and helicopters Hulk
dogs Hulk dogs you saved my life they're
from a mutant French cruel and Bruce
banners own father who's either an
unpredictable mad scientist or just nick
nolte wandering onto the set and being
himself for a few hours
resulting in an impossible to see climax
that takes place at night under water
against a cloud dad thing Thor the dark
world is looking pretty good right now
huh starring Eric banana Betsy Ross Sam
Elliott's mustache moss Nick Nolte's mug
shot and don't make him angry Salk
Hulk introspect be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers chewy
we are unhone sufferin succotash I'm a
simple man
ICPs I press like Michael Bay is a
menace the hammer of justice is unisex
I'm a lick lickilicky lollipop